je dirais pas que la justice s'acharne
la justice dans son ensemble ce serait
trop général pour être quelque chose de
de concret en revanche le d'une part le
procureur concerné n'a jamais caché sa
volonté de s'attaquer à Monsieur Trump
et d'autre part il engagé politiquement
le programme
il est affiché démocrate et puis vous
savez que vous êtes élu dans ces postes
là comme tout un tas de postes aux
États-Unis pour lesquels d'ailleurs il y
a assez peu de participation donc
forcément il y a un positionnement
politique ou en tout cas un profil
politique qui est qui est établi si on
regarde sur le plan strictement
judiciaire Donald Trump donc est mis
dans un accusation dans un dossier lié à
un inversement 130 000 dollars effectuer
à stormy Daniel ce qui est une actrice X
c'était en 2016
les Cunit tous les deux d'ailleurs les
chefs d'interculation eux ne sont pas
encore tout ce que nous dans le détail
d'une trentaine de chefs accusations
donc ça fait beaucoup de choses la clé
ce sont ces deux choses parce qu'il a
alors fédéral et puis la loi évidemment
de l'état dans lequel vous êtes sujet en
l'occurrence delta de New York donc pour
ça il y a surtout une question de
falsification de compte on va dire voilà
donc ça c'est une une offense comme on
dit en américain c'est une violation de
la loi qui est pas non plus régularité
une irrégularité ça n'est pas non plus
majeur mais c'est pour ça que les
argusies juridiques vont être très
importantes parce que pour les chefs
d'occupation de vous parler parce que la
question est de savoir si ça s'arrête là
ou bien si derrière cela contenu de la
nature du paiement et du contexte en
lequel elle s'inscrit il y avait volonté
de nuire si je puis dire au processus
électoral puisque ça veut dire que c'est
130 000 dollars dont vous parlez ont été
intégrés c'est la bêtise dans les contes
de campagne mais sans transparence
c'est-à-dire que ça a été maquillée dans
les comptes de campagne alors là du coup
vous passez à l'échelle de la Loi
fédérale sur
la loi électorale d'où les cris d'orfray
ici et là sur la menace sur la
démocratie c'est un peu exagéré quand
même mais la toile de fond c'est aussi
la personnalité de Monsieur Trump et
Trump organisation sont son entreprise
où on sait bien que ça n'est pas un
modèle de vertu comptable c'est la
première fois qu'un ancien président des
États-Unis est inculpé après son mandat
c'est la première fois et c'est sur le
fond on passe du du judiciaire aux
politiques et l'enjeu de fond en réalité
c'est son avenir politique qui est qui
est qui est en jeu dans une dans une
affaire pareille même si il y a peu à
penser alors on peut pas deviner ce qui
va se passer la décision du juge
n'appartient qu'à lui mais il y a peu à
penser qu'il termine en prison Chris
Kross que je salue nous dit pour moi
Trump va sortir renforcé de cette chasse
au sorcières de la part de l'État
profond
la question effectivement
laquelle vous commencez à répondre qui
se pose en tous les cas que beaucoup de
gens se posent c'est est-ce qu'il va
devoir survir le walk le Walk of shame
les les flashs qui crépitent devant un
Trump qui sera entouré de policiers avec
des menottes au poignet
semble-t-il pas ça ferait de lui une
victime mais il est très fort évidemment
pour retourner les situations en sa
faveur mais puisque je parle de
retournement je vous dirai que quel que
soit l'issue je n'irai pas aussi je
serai pas aussi direct sur le fait que
ça lui bénéficie tant que ça parce que
vous avez bien vu lors des élections de
mitterz qui ont été perdus par lui et
par les candidats qu'il a soutenu et
plutôt très très bien remporté
d'ailleurs c'est assez historique on n'a
pas assez dit pour Joe Biden tous les
cassis du parti républicain
jeune ou plus anciens ont exprimé le
désir de tourner la page là comme les
sondages montrent devant l'effet de zoom
de cette affaire et cette dimension qui
n'est pas
totalement fausse de chasse aux
sorcières de chasse à Trump on peut dire
qu'il a pas volé voilà pour mitiger les
choses enfin néanmoins il y a quand même
une course poursuite derrière lui vous
voyez bien que ça Hardy sa base
électorale donc du coup les classiques
en question sont neutres mais au moindre
glissement de terrain on verra
évidemment les suites de cette affaire
vous pouvez être certain que s'ils ont
l'occasion de tourner la page Trump il
la tourneront c'est tout l'enjeu pour
pour Donald Trump
où on est sa popularité aujourd'hui en
particulier depuis
l'échec desiteurs sa base est solide
mais c'est une base qui si elle est
confortable reste quand même étroite et
de mon point de vue ne peut pas
suffisante pour remporter une élection
dans deux ans nonobstant évidemment le
fait que c'est dans deux ans donc il
peut se passer quand même beaucoup de
choses enfin c'est l'année prochaine
mais comme on est au début de l'année ça
fait quand même à peu près un an et demi
jusqu'à l'investiture du parti du parti
des candidats sachant que de l'autre
côté côté démocrates pour l'instant
c'est plutôt monsieur Biden qui
s'annonce mais ça dépendra quand même de
son état de santé et je pense que
Infiniti son état de santé se maintient
ne devrait plutôt le remporter face à
Donald Trump qui n'est beaucoup moins
polarisant que Donald Trump il est le
président en exercice il y a toujours un
bonus au sortant et encore une fois je
vous le répète même si sa base est
solide
elle ne permettra pas de toucher les
catégories qui sont celles qui n'ont pas
de vote systématique on va dire bleu ou
rouge démocrate ou républicain sans
compter la force d'autres candidats
désireux de être investis on parle
beaucoup du gouverneur de Florine
Renault Santis oui
Donald Trump parle de persécution
politique mais c'est pas la première
fois qui prend ce genre de position si
ça posture préférée
oui c'est quelqu'un qui oui il a un
caractère très très singulier on va pas
revenir sur ça personnalité mais
je m'en suis déjà assez il y a longtemps
mais parce que je pense que
malheureusement il a pris de bonnes
orientations qui étaient les
orientations de sens commun et de coup
de pied dans la fourmilière notamment
vis-à-vis de la Chine vous voyez que
tout le monde a suivi du jour au
lendemain il y a eu un retournement à
cet un petit peu le signal que l'on
attendait donc c'était une bonne
politique mais qui a été
particulièrement mal exécutée pourquoi
parce que ce n'est pas du tout un homme
d'État j'en ai même pas un homme
politique c'est un caractère surgit de
ses propres horizons à lui qui a envahi
l'espace et qui est très fort pour ça
c'est un homme de télévision c'est
l'homme de médias et d'apparence mais ça
va être pas à travailleur ni un stratège
et donc malheureusement les mesures
qu'il a prises par exemple sur ce gros
sujet de la Chine ont été mauvaises même
si certaines ont été poursuivies par
l'administration actuelle puisque
forcément c'était
sans pleurs si je puis dire les les
comment dire les contre-mesures
notamment douanières des gens en place
donc il n'avait rien à faire elle n'a
pas besoin de revenir en arrière mais
c'est pour ça que je vous dis c'est
c'est quelqu'un qui comme vous le disiez
occupe beaucoup d'espace joue la
victimisation mais c'est finalement plus
qu'un jeu de rôle qu'une véritable
vision de l'Amérique même si une fois de
plus et je le rappelle je pense que sur
son patriotisme économique il a eu
raison sur le fond malheureusement pas
sur l'exécution de sa politique si on
peut parler d'une politique Kris Kross
nous dit encore je connais bien le droit
américain ça va se terminer au pire en
caution à payer il va payer cher mais
sortir libre le système judiciaire
américain est un petit peu différent
d'une autre d'abord vous le disiez cette
inculpation c'est pas une inculpation
nationale c'est-à-dire c'est pas une
occupation fédérale c'est une
inculpation qui est spécifique
l'État de New York avec le fameux
procureur du puisque c'est c'est coupé
en zone de comment dire de juridiction
l'État de New York évidemment le le
district sud de Manhattan et lég
vraiment connu pour être celui qui
notamment s'occupe des affaires
économiques qui sont un sujet et on le
comprend bien assez naturel
particulièrement sensible et important
d'où le fait que c'est ce biais là si je
peux dire qu'il après l'avoir abandonné
d'ailleurs et après avoir
réexaminé toute une enquête qui avait
démarré de manière très approfondie le
procureur actuel et revenu sur sa
première orientation qui était le lâcher
prise sur ces questions
de de compte de l'organisation de la
campagne et de Trump organisation et des
des véhicules entre les deux pour y
revenir et pour l'occuper par là alors
que il y a d'autres faits qu'on pourrait
lui reprocher il faut évidemment qu'il
soit étayé d'un point de vue juridique
comme le plus spectaculaire était
d'avoir encouragé l'assaut du Capitole
parce que ça aussi c'était historique
donc là on est par le petit bout de la
lorgnette c'est pour ça que je vous le
répète et je pense que votre intervenant
là a raison il n'y a pas en prison en
revanche c'est toute la dimension de
l'effet de zoom et tout ce que cela va
pouvoir charrier comme réaction
populaire et débat politique et là il
est de la scène donc il est sous les
projecteurs dans son rôle on a vu Steve
Bannon lui-même en Bastille et là
c'était pour des raisons de de
financement du mur à la frontière avec
le Mexique on voit également aujourd'hui
Donald Trump donc menacé par la justice
est-ce que
il y a pas un risque justement de de
développer une de donner une raison à
ceux qui pensent que Trump est
injustement persécuté et que les idées
qu'il a porté les idées qu'il représente
ou les idées que représentent banane
sont persécutés plus violemment que
celle de leurs adversaires
oui peut-être parce que sur la toile de
fond vous avez c'est le cas dans un pays
européen aussi une pensée dominante
plutôt penchant à gauche quand certaines
catégories socioprofessionnelles comme
les médias et certaines
dominants historiques comme CNN par
exemple que focus est beaucoup plus
récent
donc on peut le penser mais je pense
qu'en suite
la justice sera prise en compte
c'est-à-dire que en fonction
des
de la violation de la loi commise il y
aura toujours une partie de l'opinion
qui ne voudra pas le voir ça c'est la
continuation d'histoire la fake news
c'est-à-dire que quand on ne veut pas
croire à certaines choses on ne croit
que ce que à quoi on veut croire au fond
ça rend propre représentation de la
réalité mais que sur une autre partie
quand même de l'opinion même votant
républicains la réalité des choses va
s'imposer mais ça dépend encore une fois
de quoi il est accusé et de quoi il est
condamné et une fois de plus je pense
qu'il y aura beaucoup de bruit pour rien
on l'a dit donc train reste populaire au
sein de son électorat au sein aussi de
lecteurs républicain est toujours
candidat à la présidentielle
s'intègrent infiner changer la donne sur
sa candidature
oui elle peut ça dépend encore une fois
du quel est le chef d'accusation qui est
retenu quelles sont les conséquences
encore une fois il n'y a pas besoin de
quel chef d'accusation pour la
présidentielle
justement on parle de je vous ai dit
tout à l'heure d'une trentaine
d'accusations on le on se focalise plus
particulièrement sur les 130 000 dollars
maquillés et ça c'est quasiment
documenté et son ancien homme demain si
je puis dire Michael Cohen et
a fait beaucoup de déclarations sur ce
sujet qui ont abondé d'ailleurs
l'enquête préliminaire avant
l'incubation et
la nature si je puis dire des méfaits
aura une conséquence là-dessus et c'est
pour ça que je vous disais qu'en
fonction de la forêt les 130 000 $
pourraient le conduire à renoncer c'est
pas terrible dollars c'est la c'est là
c'est le jugement au fond moral qu'une
grande partie de l'opinion pourra et
d'abord dans le dans le dans la lectorat
républicain et ensuite et surtout dans
les établishmane républicains au sein du
parti républicain qui a encore une fois
n'attendent qu'une occasion qui est de
passer à autre chose en fonction du
crime ça donnera des arguments si vous
voulez à ces adversaires en interne qui
pourront se dévoiler si je peux est-ce
qu'il a encore des soutiens au sein du
parti républicain aujourd'hui oui oui ça
c'est certain parmi les cassis du parti
pas les cassis quand tous les cas parmi
des élus et sur plus particulièrement à
la Chambre a commencé malgré ses
relations tendues et les retournements
de ses propres relations avec le speaker
le président de la Chambre des
Représentants Kevin McCarthy avec les
difficultés qu'il a eu d'ailleurs à être
élu à la présidence associé
il a il a évidemment des soutiens vous
pensez qu'il pourrait à nouveau gagner
la présidentielle
je suis assez sceptique là-dessus
[Musique]